I hope that everybody followed you so's advice
and yesterday exercised your rights as citizens of a free state
hope.
So go ahead.
I begin today with an apology.
And that is for the particular edition that you're using for this section of the
class.
And Roussel.
This is the only addition that I've assigned in the course that I don't like.
Why did I assign it?
Because I want us to read the second discourse,
the discourse on inequality and the social contract.
And this is the only addition that I could find where they are both in the same
volume and I don't have to assign two separate books.
So in order to keep your costs down,
I bit the bullet and assigned in a translation in a d and an addition,
I don't particularly care for
a far superior addition is found in this.
This is one of the two volumes that Cambridge,
uh,
blue book series is.
It's called,
uh,
edited and translated by Gourevitch.
If anybody wants to do more advanced work in Roussel,
uh,
you will no doubt get this,
addition,
better translations,
better notes and so on of the,
uh,
second discourse and,
and the social contract.
And for anybody who's interested,
I've decided,
because Russo has become so important to me,
uh,
that next year,
I will be offering a,
an undergraduate seminar entirely devoted to Roussel.
Uh,
he's one of the handful of writers of political philosophers,
to whom one could,
you know,
uh,
justice devote an entire semester to his writings.
And,
uh,
that's what I want to do next year.
So if any of you should get the bug,
the Roussel bug next year,
we'll,
we'll do Roussel in,
in,
in many more texts in detail.
So with that,
with that having been said,
I want to talk today about a remarkable,
remarkable human being and writer.
It's a very common way of entering the thought of Rousseau to see him as a
critic of liberalism,
of the kind of property owning rights based society,
uh,
given expression by John Locke.
And I will talk about that a little bit later.
But to see Russo is a critic of Lockian liberalism a would be,
I think very short sighted and very unfair.
Russo was a product not of liberal society,
but rather of the onsie on regime,
the old regime and France Russo was born in 17,
12.
That was two years before the death of the famous Sun King Louis,
the 14th man who symbolize the age of absolutism.
And he died in 1778,
uh,
approximately a decade before the outbreak of the French revolution.
Uh,
his life in other words,
was lived entirely,
uh,
within the waning decades,
the waning years,
uh,
of the age of absolutism in France and in continental Europe.
You Russo was deeply aware that he lived in an age of transition,
but what precisely would come after,
uh,
he was by no means clear.
He wrote,
as you will see,
a with a passion,
uh,
and in,
and the intensity of someone who fully expected to be instrumental,
uh,
in the coming of a new historical and political,
epoch.
Okay.
In indeed,
he was,
Russo was Swiss.
He was not French.
He was a Swiss.
He signed many of his most important words,
simply sit [inaudible] a citizen of Geneva after the city,
uh,
where he was born.
He was the son of an artisan who abandoned his family after a falling out with
the local authorities.
And the,
and the young Roussel,
uh,
was it,
was apprentice to an engraver,
but he left Geneva.
He fled Geneva,
uh,
for good,
at the age of 16
for the following 16 years,
Russo lived a kind of vagabond,
varied life,
doing many different things,
working,
uh,
as a music instructor and a transcriber.
Uh,
he was the secretary of,
to the French ambassador in the city of Venice.
Uh,
and he was also the lover of a wealthy woman.
many years,
his senior
after moving to Paris in 1744 ru,
so spent several years eking out a living,
a sort of on the margins of the Parisian literary scene until 1750 when he
published his first,
uh,
although quite brief major essay,
a work called the discourse and the arts and the sciences,
which catapulted him to lit two literary fame that work made his name.
So it was,
it came to be called the first discourse.
That work was followed,
uh,
five years later in 1755 by the work we will be reading starting today,
the discourse and the origins of inequality often simply called the second
discourse.
And that work was followed,
uh,
later on in 1762 with the social contract.
And also the same year that Roussel published his major massive work on
political education called in meal or an education,
both in 1762 during this period,
a Russo,
uh,
fathered five children,
he abandoned all of them to an orphanage.
Uh,
he did so with a common law wife,
uh,
with whom he lived,
in,
during this times.
The writings I've mentioned are only a small portion,
although a very important portion of the writings,
ah,
which he lived.
He was also the author of a very large novel.
Halloween is the new Halloween is the new vowel Halloween's,
which was a best seller,
uh,
in his time.
And it was a kind of philosophical novel that helped you,
that explored many of his ideas.
He was the composer of an opera [inaudible] de village.
W there was a performed at the court of Louis the 15th.
Uh,
and he also wrote several very important and interesting volumes of
autobiography.
Uh,
the most famous,
the best known of which is simply called confessions,
uh,
after the work of Saint Augustan,
a title,
a book of the same name.
And he also wrote another,
uh,
volume of,
of,
of autobiography in a dialogue farm called Russo.
Jewish does genre Jacques in which he divides himself up into two different
people,
Russo and John Shock and kind of internal interrogation of himself.
Russo wrote in many and varied genres and his work spans the entire gamut of
philosophical,
literary and political themes.
He was also the,
the writer of the,
or the different constitutional projects.
He was consulted by heads of state,
uh,
in his period and wrote constitutions for,
for uh,
Poland.
Uh,
and for this small island country of Corsica,
which he said in the social contract was the only place in Europe that one might
expect great things.
And of course he was right.
Uh,
is anybody knows a generation or two later the famous Corsican yes.
Who put an end to,
who am I talking about?
Napoleon?
Of course.
Uh,
you might say he was right.
He helped to substitute the generals will for the general will,
but that was Nepal that was resolved.
People have been very baffled by exactly the nature of Rousseau's contributions.
What did he believe?
What did he stand for?
What do his writings represent?
Was he a revolutionary,
uh,
whose work help to inspire the radical phases of the French revolution?
Just remember,
for example,
you've probably all heard the famous opening sentence of the social contract man
is born free,
uh,
but is everywhere in chains.
Uh,
his appeal,
uh,
to the severe political ethics of Ancient Sparta and Rome,
as well as his belief that the people,
uh,
the people in their collective capacity or the only legitimate source of
sovereignty,
all of these seem to pave the way for the revolutionary politics of the late
18th and century and,
and,
and up and up into our own time.
So it was Russolo kind of incendiary and revolutionary,
or did his writings seek to release us all together from the bonds of society as
he appears to do in the second discourse and the discourse on inequality in this
work,
Russo seems to lay the basis for the kind of romantic individualism,
uh,
that would be associated with people like Wordsworth in England or Henry David
Thoreau in America.
Russo's direct appeals to nature as well as his,
as his celebration of the simplicity of peasant life and rural life seem to open
the door later on to writers like Tolstoy,
uh,
as well as to various kinds of social experiments in rural communal utopianism
such as,
for example,
the Israeli kibbutz and movement,
which is in its own way a direct descendant of Rousseau.
So my suggestion is Rousseau's writings are varied and his influence has been a
manifold just to say the least.
Um,
he both helps to bring to fruition and completion.
Uh,
the political and intellectual movement that we know is the enlightenment.
He brings this to its highest phase of perfection in many ways.
And at the same time,
he was a severe critic of the enlightenment.
A,
he was a close friend and associate of men like Dda,
uh,
who,
was the general editor of the encyclopedia,
the great,
the great French contribution to the age of the enlightenment.
And yet he excoriated the progress of the arts and the sciences and,
and,
and worried about their effect on the moral life of communities.
He was a writer who wore different hats.
Uh,
he defended what he called the savage survive,
uh,
against the civilized man.
Uh,
he took the side of the poor and the dispossessed,
uh,
against the elites and he adopted the posture of the loyal son and a citizen of
Geneva against the sophisticated per region intellectuals,
uh,
if his time.
So who was Russo and what did he stand for?
Uh,
that's what I want us to begin to try to find out a little about today.
Okay.
It's all right with y'all.
That works.
Okay.
The second discourse,
the discourse on inequality is in
the eyes of many readers Russo's greatest work.
I'm not sure if that's true,
but many people believe it is,
it is what writers in the 18th century called a conjectural history.
Okay.
It is that,
it's just a kind of philosophical history really.
That is to say a philosophical reconstruction of history,
but not of what actually happened in the past.
It's not a history of facts and dates,
but it is a history.
Russo believes of what had to have happened for in a way,
human beings to evolve to their current condition.
Rousseau begins the work by comparing the effects of history on us to the
statute of glaucous.
Uh,
did,
he says the winds and storms had so disfigured that it's scarcely looked like a
human being at all.
This is what history in time has done to us.
It has so affected and transformed human nature did.
If we want to understand what human nature really is,
he argues it is necessary to reconstruct it through a kind of thought
experiment.
Okay.
Russo at the outset,
is that okay?
Is that,
was that for me?
Okay.
No,
uh,
if it was my wife,
I tell her I'll get the canola is not to worry.
Roussel compares the second one.
Describe.
Oh dear.
All right.
Roussel compare
bad to laugh at your own,
you know,
jokes.
He
compares the second discourse,
uh,
to an experiment like those undertaken by physicists and cosmologists in his own
day who speculate about the origins of the universe in the same way that he's,
he is speculating about the original condition of human nature.
That is to say,
uh,
there is no empirical or physical evidence to draw on to understand how the
world was actually framed.
We can only make,
he says,
intelligent guesses,
certain inferences or conjectures based on the evidence that we find around us.
And so Roussel remarks in one of the most arresting passages from his book and
Russo is a man known for writing,
arresting,
paradoxical and and ingenious sentences.
He writes,
let us therefore begin by putting aside all the facts.
Let us put all the stacks facts aside for they have no bearing on the case.
The investigation that may be undertaken concerning this subject should not be
taken for historical truth.
He says,
but only for hypothetical and conditional reasonings.
In other words,
what he's saying is that the history that he intends to unfold is an experiment,
much like again,
net undertaken by geologists who try to infer the development of plant or animal
life from the existence of certain fossil remains or skeletal remains.
And yet at the same time,
while Russo speaks of his work is tentative,
experimental conjectural,
he is only hazarded some guesses.
He writes,
you cannot help but be struck by the certain tone of confidence,
uh,
with which he presents his findings.
In particular,
he discusses and rejects quite emphatically the investigations of his
predecessors,
both ancient and modern.
The philosophers he wrote to have examined the foundations of society of all
felt the necessity of returning to the state of nature,
but none of them has reached it.
Rousseau says he believes that he alone has finally,
as it were,
struck gold.
Oh Man.
He exclaimed,
Oh man,
whatever country you may be from,
whatever your opinions may be.
Listen,
here is your history.
As I have thought to read it,
not in the books of your fellow men who are liars,
but in nature,
who never lies.
That's a remarkable sentence for the first time.
Rousseau says,
human nature will be revealed.
And the history of civil society explained,
explained to us here,
Ma,
listen,
here is your history.
It's,
I have read it,
not through other books,
but through nature.
He says,
that seems to speak directly to me or to which I have,
uh,
an insight.
So what is the state of nature,
a term that we've been looking at in Hobbes and Locke?
What is it that Rousseau thinks he has found that the,
that alluded his predecessors.
Okay.
In many ways we've already seen,
I've already suggested Roussel follows in the footsteps of his great
predecessors,
particularly Hobbes and Locke,
and attempting to understand the original condition,
uh,
by referring to this hypothetical or conjectural state of nature.
In many ways,
he praises and follows a Hobbes and Locke in doing this,
but suggests that they never really took the problem of nature seriously enough.
Uh,
what does it mean?
Roussel seems to ask us to take nature,
uh,
human nature,
the state of nature.
What does it mean to take nature seriously
again,
to understand it,
but to understand human nature?
What it originally is,
is to conduct a sort of thought experiment where we peel away almost like the
layers of an onion.
Uh,
everything that we have acquired through the influence of time of history,
of custom and tradition in order to discover what is naturally there.
So when Hobbs tells us,
uh,
or when he attributes to natural man certain warlike propensities,
Rousseau figures that this cannot be right,
a war and the passions that give rise to war can only come into being once we
are in society.
The state of war is really the simply the state of society.
This cannot be hold for natural man because natural,
the natural conditions had no so strong social relationships of this sword.
And you might say his statement was Ditto for John Locke.
When lock attributes to us in the state of nature,
certain qualities of rationality,
of industry,
of acquisitiveness.
These two Roussel complaints are only qualities that we can acquire in the light
of society.
Property entails social relations between persons,
relations of justice and injustice.
And Man in the state of nature is not a social animal.
So it is clear for Roussel that human nature is something infinitely remote and
strange.
Uh,
then any of his predecessors had ever imagined what was the condition of natural
man Russo's captivated readers in his time and since by showing that the
original condition of human nature was far more like an animal than anything,
uh,
identifiably or recognizably Human Russo takes great delight in analyzing a
human nature.
Analyzing us when Aristotle said that man is the rational being because we
possess speech or logos,
Rousseau says wrong.
Again,
language is dependent upon society and could only have developed over literally
thousands of generations and cannot be a property,
uh,
of natural man.
Human nature is a little different from animal nature and in many ways Russo
delights in.
You can see this in his footnotes in particular in investigating or stories
about a rang of tanks and other species that he believes in many ways are our
distant ancestors.
Uh,
you might say a century before Darwin,
a Russo could just have easily entitled his second discourse on the origins of
the species.
Uh,
in many ways the whole science of,
you know,
evolutionary biology is already in many ways implicit here.
And yet for all of our features are common features with other species.
Russo specifies two qualities that set us apart.
The first is the quality of freedom or what he calls free agency.
Although he understands this and this very specific way,
let me read a relevant,
are crucial passage in any animal,
uh,
Roussel rights.
Uh,
in any animal I see nothing but an ingenious machine to which nature has given,
uh,
senses in order for it to renew its strength and to protect itself to a certain
point,
uh,
from all that tends to disturb it.
I am aware of precisely the same thing in the human machine.
In other words,
he says,
animals are just simply little machines that operate by a mechanical or,
or physical impulses and needs and desires.
And the same is true.
He says in the human,
a machine with this difference,
that nature alone does everything in the operations of an animal where his man
contributes as a free agent to his own operations.
Man contributes as a free agent to his own operations.
What does he mean there?
And saying that man is a free agent.
Uh,
this idea of free agency in many ways sounds similar and indeed it is to Hobbes
and Locke,
both of whom who said freedom,
uh,
free,
free freedom of will,
some kind of freedom is,
is,
is a characteristic of natural man or natural pre-social ah,
man.
But Roussel seems to add to this something different.
Freedom for Hobbes or Locke simply means the freedom to choose to do this or
that the freedom to exercise the will and not to be interfered with by others
around us.
Roussel also believes that,
uh,
but in many ways he adds something else to it.
He connects freedom in this same passage to what he calls the,
the phenomenon or the,
or the quality of the Faculty of perfectability.
Perfectibility tay,
what does he mean in connecting freedom with,
he calls with what he calls perfectability perfectability for Rousseau suggests
an openness,
a sort of unlimit,
virtually unlimited openness to change.
Uh,
we are the species who not only have the freedom to do this or that,
but we are the species who have the freedom as it were to become this or that.
It is our very openness to change that accounts for our mutability over time as
a species.
In other words,
we are,
you might say,
uniquely under determined,
uh,
meaning that our nature is not confined in advance to what it may become.
Rather,
our nature for Russo is uniquely suited to alter and transform itself,
uh,
as circumstances change and as we adapt,
adapt and adopt to new and unforeseen situations.
Perfectability for result is not so much a feature of the individual,
but it is as it is of the species.
And again,
whereas Hobbes or Locke assume that human nature itself remained more or less
constant,
uh,
in the transition from what they called the state of nature to the civil state.
Uh,
Russo believes that human nature has undergone manifold revolutions is,
as he called it,
over this source,
uh,
of time.
What we are at any one phase of human history or human evolution will be very,
very different from what we are at any other particular phase.
And it is this what he calls distinctive and unlimited faculty that he says,
is that also the source of all of our misfortunes?
So when he says that we are characterized by freedom and associates freedom with
perfectability,
he doesn't necessarily mean,
uh,
by perfectability that which,
perfects us.
He also says it is that which is at the source of our miseries and our dis
content's in many ways.
If you wanted to give this book another title,
I've already suggested one for the origin of the species.
It could just as well have been called more than a century before Freud
civilization and its discontents,
uh,
which was in many ways Fried's attempt to rewrite Russo's account of the
evolution of the human species.
But Russo notes in this same park that freedom or perfectibility is not our sole
natural characteristic,
although it is responsible in some way for almost everything that we have
become.
Everything that we have become is due to this openness to change.
Uh,
in addition to perfectability and freedom is the quality that Rousseau calls PTA
or pity,
compassion.
And here is in a sense,
Russo at his most characteristic you could say,
here is Roussel the founder of Romanticism.
Okay.
Man is not the rational animal,
the thinking being the being with logos,
but we are the sensitive creature who so fines all kinds of evidence,
uh,
for assuming that compassion is part of our original nature.
He notes in other species a reluctance,
uh,
to witness the pain or suffering of another of its own kind.
How an animal will not,
uh,
wish to walk near a dead member of its own species.
That seems to indicate to Rousseau,
um,
even in the other species,
a kind of natural core of,
of compassion or pity.
The fact that we cry at the misfortunes of others who have nothing to do with us
is evidence of our original sensitivity.
Uh,
do we not enjoy crying and movies?
Yeah,
it's someone in here ever cried in a movie.
Yes.
Dot.
We all have,
uh,
even at people or objects that don't exist.
Did we not feel pity for King Kong?
When we saw that movie,
did we not?
Did we not feel pity for a fictional creature that could,
could not exist,
but yet,
whose,
whose faith somehow effected us in some way and Rousseau would under completely
understands us in giving man tears.
Rousseau writes nature bears witness that she gave the human race the softest of
hearts.
The softest of hearts man is the sensitive creature.
So much so that reus so finds evidence in this for what he believes is our
natural goodness.
The natural goodness of man in the state of nature is to some degree borne out
by this quality of pity or compassion that we even share with are their species.
Why does Russo emphasize this quality?
Because it is deeply important to him.
Uh,
you might say
long before Dr Phil in thousands of other,
you know,
self help gurus and,
and self help manuals,
Roussel taught us to get in touch with our feelings.
One natural man may be compassionate and kind.
However,
that sentiment he tells us is easily overpowered by more powerful passions.
Once we enter society,
once we become civilized or socialized,
we see once we are in society to care about others and we become calculating in
mercenary,
in our motives.
Selfishness and ego.
Ism are in fact reinforced for him by the development of reason.
Reason he writes is what in genders,
egoism and reflections strengthens it.
The development of rationality.
He thinks,
uh,
simply hastens or corruption by the assisting in the development of different
vices.
And the task of the second discourse,
at least it's rhetorical task,
is in many ways to recover our natural selves,
compassionate,
gentle,
kind from the artificial corrupt and calculating selves we have all become in
civil society and who can't read that in Roussel without realizing that there is
a significant germ of truth in what?
In what he says.
Um,
did you so believe it possible then or desirable to return to this state of
nature to risk,
to return to some kind of Prelab Sarian condition before the beginnings of civil
society?
He is frequently read as saying this,
uh,
when Voltaire wrote a red rather the second discourse,
he said,
never has so much intelligence been expended in the attempt to turn us back into
brutes and that is clever.
Uh,
but it's not really right.
Voltaire surely knew that 150 years before Russo,
uh,
there was a French writer by the name of Montana,
Michelle de Montalban,
who had written an important essay called on cannibals in which he described the
Indian tribes off the coast of Brazil,
whom he praised against the true savagery and barbarism of their European
conquerors.
When he calls that essay,
that famous essay,
Michelle Call Montanan calls of cannibals.
It is an open question of who the cannibals are.
Are they that the natives of the Brazilian coast
or are they again the European conquerors and maintain like Rousseau,
but a century or more before praised?
Uh,
in many ways the qualities and the capacities of these survive,
uh,
that he discovered a and contrasted them to that bloodthirsty cruelty of the
Europeans,
uh,
of his own day.
Russo was deeply influenced by this particular essay and it's a short essay and
I would suggest at some point when you have a chance you read it,
but in any case Roussel makes it plain that return to the state of nature or
some kind of pre social or pre civil state is no longer an option for civilized
beings.
In one of the footnotes,
and I encourage you to read the footnote,
very important footnotes in his,
in his book,
Rousseau writes,
what then must we destroy societies and Naya late dine in mind and return to
live in the forest with the bears a conclusion.
He writes in a style of my adversaries,
which I prefer to anticipate rather than to leave to them the shame of drawing
and he says,
in other words,
no,
we can't do that or return to the state of nature is impossible for us for the
same reason it would be like returning a domestic animal back to the wild.
They and we have simply lost our instinct for self preservation.
It has been dulled by continual association and dependence on others.
We would not last a single day.
So if a return to nature is impossible,
the only alternative in some way is to remain in society.
But before we can learn how to live in society,
Roussel wants to tell the story of how it is man became civilized,
so to speak.
How the transition from nature to culture or from nature to society in fact
occurred.
Uh,
in one sense,
okay.
Russo's account of this story can be given in a single word
property.
The first sentence of part two of the discourse reads as follows,
the first person who having enclosed a piece of land took it into his head to
say this is mine,
and found people simple enough to believe him was the true founder of civil
society.
Okay?
Lock would certainly agree in some respects,
but Roussel continues as follows.
Okay?
What crimes was murderers,
murderers,
what miseries and horrors with the human race have been spared?
Had someone pulled up,
the stakes are filled in the ditch and cried out to his fellow men,
do not listen to this imposter.
You are lost if you forget that the fruits of the earth belonged to all and the
earth to no one
there you see and a germ in many ways,
his repudiation of Loc was toe,
was not a communist,
although this sounds very much in some respects like Karl Marx.
He was not a communist.
Uh,
he did not feel it was either again,
possible or desirable to do away with private property or to collect,
devise property and the manner of a Plato or a marks,
but there is no one
okay
of whom I am aware who is a more acute observer of the ills of class and the
effects of private property.
Then Russo,
uh,
he believed that there was something deeply wrong with a conception of
government,
uh,
as the protector of private property that intervenes as little as necessary with
the affairs of individuals leaving them simply free to pursue life,
liberty,
and it's state as they would see fit Russo in many ways points back to an older,
it might take classical conception of government,
of the ancient Polis and ancient republic,
one,
uh,
for which politics,
had the task among other things of supervising the pursuit and acquisition of
property,
mitigating the harshest effects of economic inequalities.
And it's very,
in a single sentence from Russo's first discourse,
the discourse on the arts and sciences in many ways says it all.
Ancient politicians he wrote,
spoke only about morals and virtues.
Ours speak only of commerce and money.
That was Russo's complaint.
Uh,
no talk any longer of civic virtue and citizenship.
Okay.
Oh,
Russo,
uh,
excuse me.
Locke's view recall from just a couple of days ago is that the emancipation or
the of acquisition makes everyone better in locks.
Famous formula a day laborer in England is how is clothed and fed better than a
King of the Americas.
And Rousseau believed that from a strictly you might take economic point of
view.
There is certainly a lot of truth to this,
but he also realized that from the economic point of view or that the economic
point of view barely began to scratch the surface of things,
Russo is far more impressed,
you might say,
by the proud dignity and independence,
uh,
of the native American King.
Then with all the luxuries and conveniences that have made European kings and
even some European day laborers,
uh,
soft and dependent,
in his word,
Russo is deeply impressed.
And again,
you see this in his footnotes with the kind of unassimilatable character of
native peoples,
Icelanders Greenlanders hot and tots.
He writes all of their refusal to assimilate in many ways to European religion
and custom or they prefer their personal independence.
He writes to the comforts and luxuries of modern civilization.
Consider the following passage,
which one of the passages I love,
uh,
in this book that comes from his footnotes.
He says,
savages have often been brought to Paris,
London,
and other cities.
People have been eager to display our luxury,
our wealth and all are most useful and curious arts to them.
None of this has ever excited in them anything but a stupid admiration without
the least stirring of covetousness.
I recall among others the story of the chief of some North Americans who was
brought to the court of England about 30 years ago.
He writes a thousand things were made to pass before his eyes in an attempt to
give him some present that could please him,
but nothing was found.
That about which he seemed to care our weapons seemed heavy and cumbersome to
him.
Our shoes hurt.
His feet are closed,
restricted him.
He rejected everything.
Finally,
it was noticed that having taken a wool blanket,
he seemed to take some pleasure and wrapping it around his shoulders.
You will agree at least someone immediately said to him on the usefulness of
this furnishing,
yes,
he replies,
this seems to be nearly as good as an animal skin.
However,
Rousseau says he would not have said that had he Warren,
both of them in the rain.
And there's kind of Rousseau sense of,
of the virtual,
again,
the proud independence of the native of the salvage as he calls him to the
decadents.
The corruptness,
the softness of,
of,
of the modern European,
uh,
Russo was assertion that market economies,
and the governments that protect,
uh,
them do in a sense make our people better off.
And yet,
despite this fact,
he realized that market economies also introduced vast inequalities between
human beings.
And this is a trade off that Rousseau seem unwilling to make or wish to make,
even though I would have to say most Americans seem fairly happy with this trade
off,
perhaps because we have,
we either are or have become kind of natural lock-ins.
Uh,
but that again is a bargain or a trade off that Roussel was at least unwilling
to accept.
He was not only impressed with what was gained by the progress of civilization,
but more impressed,
so to speak,
by what was lost.
It's inequalities increase.
We are forced to become greedy,
calculating,
acquisitive again,
our natural pity or compassion is easily overcome by these more powerful
passions.
Uh,
what becomes of our original goodness and natural decency.
natural man for Russo,
thought of himself but only of himself,
whereas civilized man is forced to think of others,
but we do so only in a calculating in mercenary way,
thinking of them as means to our own ends.
Even a social bond itself,
even as social contract,
uh,
is simply an agreement among business partners,
so to speak,
the most bourgeois of institutions.
Uh,
the contract,
the fact is Roussel believes,
uh,
under modern conditions,
natural man is transformed into a bourgeois.
Uh,
Russo is one of the first to use that term in,
in quite that way,
locks,
rational and industrious man was for Roussel simple,
simply the calculating bourgeois and unlike the natural man who thinks only of
himself or of the classical citizen of Rome or Sparta who thinks only of the
common good in his public duties,
the bourgeois inhabits a kind of halfway house,
neither capable of the original or spontaneous goodness,
nor of political heroism or self sacrifice.
In short,
our modern people have become kind of knowledges,
uh,
nowhere,
men,
man,
you might say in the title of the Beatles Song,
how did that happen?
How did we become
put in this situation?
I've suggested one answer or Rousseau suggest one,
answer the development of property,
but that's only part of the story.
And what I want to do for next week is tell another very important,
in some respects,
even more important part of that story of how we have become the way we are.
So,
uh,
anyway,
have a good weekend.
Uh,
go to the football game and we're going to win win against Princeton.